dis moi alors à un moment on parle de
pétition contre le réchauffement de la
planète à moi aussi je suis traité comme
d'anciennes puis les pétitions attendait
avec deux pétitions de la tour de bras
ac c'est vrai qu'elles arrivent par fax
chez toi vraiment vous trouvez
malheureux avec quelques-unes comme ça
et tu laisses ignorant changer quoi
trois par semaine
c'est par là trois par semaine la
dernière c'est là qu'elle par exemple
c'était pour la suppression du double
jeu cela j'en ai reçus pour contre la
fermeture d'un centre culturel en
turquie tous les militaires vont fermer
bien sûr elle est jaune là dedans 30 la
musique et tout violet santa pétition
pour le retour à la monarchie mais
chemin alors question écologique quand
même tu es toujours un militant tu
plantes des arbres et c'est d'ailleurs
en veut un peu à cousteau tout le monde
aime bien cousteau toi comme tu as une
grande gueule et puis j'aime bien
l'ouvrir sadiku ce qu'il a réussi à me
cacher les nets les morts non c'est pas
ça mais c'est que cousteau tu as dit tu
as raison il aurait mieux fait de venir
à la centrale nucléaire de nogent sur
seine
parce que c'était plus important pour
nos enfants que de se battre contre les
crados
non c'est c'est vrai il avait une fois
dans sa vie pouce auraient vécu
longtemps c'est quand il c'est un sur un
digne et contre les grades autre appel
n'est pas l'image vient de mourir de
rire les enfants à l'école qui venait
mourir de rire les parents c'était
vraiment drôle
outre son écologie personnels formés ou
parce que je vois que tu fume des
cigarettes quand même ses mauvais choix
pourquoi tu me fais penser tu vas pas
nous faire avec les cigarettes comme
foucault et martin avec les régimes ne
soit pas t'arrêter recommence et
arrêtait recommencer le nom là j'arrête
c'est fini la carte et un terminal
donc c'est le 11 mai 92 10 ans le donc
si vous voyez fumer après transmet 92
prévu un bon pour engueuler honte à toi